in november when twitter co-founder and
ceo jack dorsey announced he was
stepping down he also named his
successor parag agarwal a twitter
veteran many saw agarwal as a natural
fit to replace dorsey agarwal joined
twitter in 2011 following stints at
microsoft at t in yahoo he first worked
on twitter's ad team where using machine
learning mr agarwal and his colleagues
developed ways to target ads to users
which helped raise twitter's revenues
and his profile by the time dorsey
returned to twitter as ceo in 2015
agarwal was already an influential
engineer in the company according to
reporting by the new york times mr
agarwal also managed twitter's effort to
incorporate cryptocurrencies into the
platform in 2017 twitter promoted mr
agarwal to chief technology officer
agarwal's experience working on the
product side helped assuage investors
who feared the company was stagnating
but shortly after he was named twitter's
new ceo agarwal drew criticism from
conservatives as old social media posts
and interviews led some to question how
agarwal would handle censorship
specifically some conservative
commentators pointed to auger while
telling mit technology review in 2020
that twitter like other private
companies isn't bound by the first
amendment leading some conservative
commentators to speculate that twitter's
censorship of right-wing sources will
worsen
beyond the negative political publicity
twitter does face an uphill battle
agarwal's job handed down to him from
investors including activist firm
elliott management is to grow twitter to
315 million active users and reach 7.5
billion dollars in revenue by the end of
2023 substantially higher than its
current figures analysts worry it will
be difficult for it to meet the targets
set before dorsey's departure and
twitter's stock has suffered the stock
dropped more than 40 percent over the
six months before elon musk announced he
had become twitter's largest shareholder
but the day of the announcement
twitter's share price jumped 27
in early may agarwal announced the
departure of twitter's general manager
for consumer products and general
manager for revenue in a memo to
employees agarwal also said twitter was
pausing most new hiring and pulling back
on discretionary spending however the
company is not currently planning
layoffs part of this stems from the
company not hitting goals in audience
and revenue growth mr agarwal wrote but
on twitter outgoing general manager
kayvon bakpour said agarwal asked him to
step down because he wants to quote take
the team in a new direction
on may 13th elon musk said on twitter
that the sale is on hold over his
concerns over the number of fake and
spam accounts on the site on twitter
aquawall questioned the ability of the
company to confirm which accounts are
real to which musk responded with a poop
emoji
[Music]
you